أغنية جديدة E
افعلها
لقد حدث
الآن كل طفل ليس بهذا الثراء
يحدث أن يذهب سوبهاش إلى المدرسة وفي المساء يذهب
اذهب للرسوم الدراسية ودفع الرسوم، إذا كنا
يتم توزيع الكتب على الأطفال مجاناً وإرسالها إلى منازلهم.
إذا أعطينا المال فسيزداد تعليمهم.
ويتجنب الطرق الخاطئة والطرق السيئة.
سوف ينفق سمه على هذا الكتاب
سوف تفعل سوف تحصل على معلومات منه
مساعدة اماركاتها موجودة في هذه الصورة.
شرح إيشارا أو شاكتيم في Photo My Photo
منطقة
افعلها
أغنية جو مارا سناوات في Doosra Lootera
2006 قاد الوقت بلقب الرجل
امزجها وكم الراتب الشهري في هذا الجانب؟
خمسة ODIs واثنان
أنه في خضم الغضب أرادت الشمس أبا
لتشغيل هذا الكتاب من خلال MoneyGram
أبحاث سوق أدوات سوق الطغيان
المفردات أوو
أننا ندير حاليا صغيرة جدا
وزيرنا لديه ميزانية قدرها 18 ألف روبية لذلك نحن
إذا حصلت على التبرع وحصل عليه، فنحن
وذلك بزيادتها من أكثر من أربع قرى إلى 40 قرية
سيصل معبد Tehsil إلى الطريق في هذا الوقت
إذا كان الجمل يعمل فسوف نقوم بتحصيلك
ومن العاشرة أن هذا المسجد سوف ينتشر بسبب الناس
يحب كثيرا
[موسيقى]
افعلها